-Welcome back, everyone.
We're talking to Ariana DeBose
right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you're hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend.
But let's talk
"West Side Story."
Man, oh, man,
I think this is --
Yeah, you are phenomenal in it.
-Thank you.
-I think you got nominated
for over 40 awards or something.
-It's wild.
-It's wild, right?
But congrats.
When you get the call to do --
is it like,
"Hey, Steven Spielberg wants
to meet you for his new movie"?
Or do you know that
it's "West Wide" or what's...?
-No, I was doing "Summer,"
the Donna Summer musical,
at the time.
I was singing -- ♪ oh, no ♪
eight times a week.
-That's right.
-And I was really tired
one evening after the show,
and Cindy Tolan,
the casting director, called,
and she goes, "Hey,
can you come to Brooklyn
tomorrow at 10:00 a.m.?"
And I was like, "But it's, like,
11:30 p.m. eight now."
-You're like -- ♪ oh, no ♪
-♪ Oh, no ♪
And she was like,
"No, just come."
And I was like, "Great.
So can I just dance and sing?"
And she was like,
"Sure, sure, sure. I got you."
So I get there the next day,
and I walk into the room,
and there's Steven Spielberg
and Tony Kushner.
And I was like, "Hmm."
[ Imitates explosion ]
-Wow.
-And I said,
"Am I gonna do this right now?
I'm gonna do this right now.
Okay."
So I danced for him,
and he really liked my dancing,
and then he said,
"Will you sing?"
And I was like, "Sure."
And I then I sing for him,
and he really likes my singing.
He was like, "Great."
And I said --
He said, "Will you read?"
And I said, "No."
-[ Laughter ]
-What?
-And he said, "No?"
And I was like, "No, sir."
-You don't say "no"
to Steven Spielberg.
-I -- I realize that, but...
[ Laughter ]
No, I had said the night before.
I was like -- Look.
These scenes -- Like, these are
Tony Kushner expanded scenes.
They can be wordy.
-You gotta nail it.
-And they're important.
You gotta nail it.
And quite frankly I'm not in the
business of going in a room
as a Black woman
and not getting it right.
You got to come in prepared.
And I was just like,
"I'm going to tell him no,
but I'd love to come back."
And so he -- the -- Literally,
that was his next question
after I couldn't get the rest
of my declarative statement out.
-Wow.
-And, uh --
-Good for you.
-He said, "Will you come back?"
And I said, "I'd be honored."
And then, you know,
a couple weeks later,
he called me in a nail salon,
with the foils on my nails.
[ Laughter ]
And he said, "Hi. It's Steven.
I'm on an airplane."
I was like, "That is so great.
Um, one second."
-"Guys, Steven Spielberg's
on the phone!
Can everyone just quiet down?
It's happening."
-"Quit that drying over there."
-"This is real over here."
-And he asked me
if I would be his Anita.
And I was like -- [ Gasping ]
-You're Anita.
And you got the biggest song
in the movie.
-Yeah, crazy, crazy.
-"America."
-I can't --
-Are you serious?
-I can't believe it.
-It's gorgeous, by the way.
-Thank you.
-It is --
What was it like on set?
I mean, is it --
-Oh, it's wild.
I mean, Steven Spielberg sets
are huge.
-The wardrobe is great.
The choreography.
-Everything! I mean,
Paul Tazewell's costumes.
It's like a color explosion.
-It's amazing.
-But I kid you not --
it's like going to summer camp,
and Steven and Tony
are your camp counselors.
And, you know --
-Wow.
-We finished like six days
of "Dance at the Gym,"
and I'm really tired
and I'm eating a Pop-Tart,
And Steven's like
"Addie. What is that?"
And I said, "It's a Pop-Tart.
Are you judging me?"
And he was like, "No.
What flavor are you eating?"
And I said, "Cinnamon sugar."
-Ooh. Okay.
-"Brittany, can I get
a strawberry Pop-Tart?!"
-No way.
-I kid you not.
It's summer camp.
-Wow. You bonded over Pop-Tarts?
-Over Pop-Tarts. It was great.
-See, he's a smart dude.
I love Steven Spielberg.
I -- Yeah.
He toast his?
-He eats Pop-Tarts.
-You ever do them raw?
-I'm a raw Pop-Tart girl.
-Me too! I'm a raw!
I'm a sushi Pop-Tart...
-Hey! [ Laughs ]
-Me too. Me too.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ariana DeBose performing
"America" in "West Side Story."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ariana DeBose!
"West Side Story"
is in theaters now.
Catch her this weekend
hosting "Saturday Night Live,"
with musical guest Bleachers.